>> Mark Sweeney: Good afternoon.
Welcome to the Library
of Congress.
I'm Mark Sweeney, the
Principal Deputy Librarian
and it's my pleasure to
welcome you here today
to the historic Thomas
Jefferson building
for this afternoon's panel
discussion, The United States
and World Legacy of the
Paris Peace Conference.
It's hosted by the John
W. Kluge Center here
at the Library of Congress.
On January 18th, 1919, the
Paris Peace Conference opened.
Today, almost 100 years later,
we gather to discuss the legacy
of a pivotal period
for world history.
So the library's
been very involved
in commemorating the role of the
United States in World War I.
Our exhibition Echoes from the
Great War: America's Experiences
in World War I, located
in the galleries just off the
great hall on the second floor,
opened to the public
in April of 2017.
When the library staff began
to develop the expedition,
they recognized that many
Americans had an interest
in learning more about the
United States during this
important period in our history.
The number of visitors
witness to that interest.
Since its opening, more
than 1.25 million visitors
have toured the exhibition.
Echoes of the Great War
examines the upheaval
of the World War
as Americans confronted it,
both at home and abroad.
The exhibition considers
the debates and struggles
that surrounded US engagement,
explores US military and
home front mobilization
and the immensity of
industrialized warfare,
and touches on the worst effects
as an international peace
settlement was negotiated.
National borders were
redrawn and soldiers returned
and reintegrated into
American society.
Well, with the most
comprehensive collection
of multi-format World War
I holdings in the nation,
including those materials
that we gathered and preserved
in the library's
Veterans History Project,
the library uses unique
exhibitions to tell stories
through words and
images of those both
in seats of power but as
well as the lesser-known
participants whose lives were
shaped by the war.
Featuring newly digitized film
footage, some not seen in more
than 100 years, Echoes of the
Great War visits a turning
of the tide in American history.
In addition to the expedition,
papers from President
Woodrow Wilson from his time
in the White House, also
as a scholar of New Jersey,
have been digitized and are
available from the Library
of Congress more than 100
years after his presidency.
The Wilson papers, the largest
presidential collection held
by the library,
consisting of approximately
280,000 documents and comprising
about 620,000 images,
the collection reflects
Wilson's innovative efforts
and accomplishment and
the enduring controversies
he engendered.
Many of these documents
are featured
in the library's exhibit.
So if you haven't visited yet,
please take some time to go
out to the great hall,
to the second floor,
to see the exhibit
before it closes
on Monday, January the 21st.
Before we begin,
I especially want
to thank panelist Michael
Neiberg for serving as
one of our expert
advisors and consultants
to the Echoes of the Great War.
Thanks are also due
to Margaret MacMillan
for her own advisory
contributions
to this landmark exhibition.
And now I'd like to invite
Kluge director John Haskell
to the podium to introduce
our distinguished panel.
John?
>> John Haskell:
Thank you, Mark.
At the Kluge Center,
our in-resident scholars
have been awarded fellowships
and chairs in competitive
processes to take advantage
of the library collections in
their work in the humanities
and the social sciences.
The fundamental aim
of the center is
to bring relevant scholarship
to the attention of Congress,
other policymakers, as well
as the interested public
by a variety of means,
including events like this.
Our panel chair,
Margaret MacMillan
who is the driving
force behind this event,
I want to recognize
her as Mark just did.
I also want to thank
the panelists
who haven't been recognized yet,
Harold James and
Charlie Kupchan.
Margaret has been on the Library
Scholars Council since 2012,
and get ready to be impressed.
The council advises the Kluge
Center and the librarian
of Congress on a range of
issues including nominations
for Kluge Center chairs
and the Kluge Prize.
We're grateful to Margaret for
all the ways she's been involved
with the library over
the last seven years.
She's professor of history
at the University of Toronto.
Previously she was the warden of
St. Anthony's College at Oxford.
She is a prolific author.
Her most recent book about
World War I is titled The Road
to 1914: The War
that Ended Peace.
Among her many honors, she is
a fellow of the Royal Society
of Literature and a senior
fellow of Massey College
at the University of Toronto.
She is an honorary
fellow of Trinity College,
University of Toronto,
and honorary fellow
of Lady Margaret Hall and
of St. Hilda's College,
University of Oxford.
She's also a trustee of the
Central European University
in Budapest, and sits
on the Editorial Board
of International History
and First World War Studies.
She's also a companion of honor.
She's a trustee of
the Rhodes Trust.
In 2006, Professor MacMillan
was invested as an officer
of the Order of Canada and then
in 2015 became a companion.
Without further ado,
let me turn the event
over to Margaret MacMillan.
The lectern is blocking
some view here,
so we have a couple folks who
are going to be moving that,
but don't worry about that.
Thanks, Travis.
If you were going move over
there I think you better not.
>> Margaret MacMillan: I'll
wait for the lectern to move.
Well, while you're
moving the lectern,
let me say thank you very much
for that very nice welcome
from both the deputy librarian
and the head of the
Kluge Center.
It's a great privilege
and pleasure to be here
in this very beautiful building,
and it's a great moment I think
to be talking about what
the First World War meant
for the United States.
We know that it meant a
great deal for the world,
but it also meant
a lot to people
who were involved in that war.
And I think it was a war in
which old orders were destroyed.
Russia had its revolution,
Austria-Hungary disappeared,
the Ottoman Empire disappeared
shortly after the war ended.
But it also marked the
arrival of new powers,
not least among them -- in
fact foremost among them the
United States.
And I think we'll be
hearing in this panel
about how the United States
through its participation
in the war, and it was a
controversial participation,
but what it did was help
to create the modern
America of today.
It helped to give the United
States a sense of itself
and its place in the world.
It also of course left
a legacy of debate
over whether the
United States should
or should not have
gone into that war.
But I think you can
see the First World War
and American involvement
in the making of the peace
as a very important step
towards the emergence
of the United States as
a major power and then
of course a super power
on the world stage.
And I think we're very lucky
on this panel to have people
who have been thinking
about these issues
for a great many years
and writing about them.
We're going to each talk
for about ten minutes,
and then we'll have a few
comments among ourselves.
We may disagree with each other.
This sometimes happens
with academics.
I'm warning you.
And we may agree with each
other which happens more rarely.
And then we'll throw
it open for questions
and comments from the floor.
We're going to go in
the following order,
and I won't give long
introduction to the panelists,
although they deserve it,
because you have I think
before you the program.
And I think it's more important
that they get the
chance to speak.
But the first speaker will be
Michael Neiberg who's going
to talk about World War I and
the creation of the US identity.
Michael, among many other
things, is the inaugural chair
in war studies at
the Army War College.
He's been thinking and writing
about the First World
War for a long time.
I first encountered him through
one of his books called Dance
of the Furies: Europe and
the Outbreak of War in 1914,
which is a wonderful look
at that world that was
about to be destroyed.
And one of his latest works,
I think his last book,
is The Path to War: How
the First World War Created
Modern America.
Harold James, who's then
going to speak, is professor
of history at Princeton
University as well
as in the University's
Woodrow Wilson School of Public
and International Affairs.
He writes international history
with a particular interest
in the financial
international history.
And his scale is extraordinary.
He goes from the Roman
Empire to the present.
He wrote a book on Weimer
Germany, he wrote a book
on the European monetary union.
And in 2001 he wrote a book
that unfortunately was rather
prescient called The End
of Globalization.
His most recent book is The
Euro and the Battle of Ideas.
Charles Kupchan is both
practitioner and a scholar.
He was national security
director
in President Obama's
administration
for European affairs.
But he teaches and
writes at Georgetown.
His most recent book is No
One's World: The Rising Rest
and the Coming Global Turn.
He is a frequent
commentator in the press
and writes f foreign
affairs quite often.
In September 2018 he published
an article called Trump's 19th
Century Grand Strategy.
His current work
is on isolationism.
You needn't see a
connection there,
but this is what he's
working on at the moment.
So I'm going to ask Michael
if he would start by talking.
And then I'm going to follow
him and then I'm going to talk
about the United States and
the making of the peace,
and then Harold James
and then Charles Kupchan.
So Michael?
>> Michael Neiberg: Thank you.
Thank you, Margaret.
Thank you to everybody for
taking up part of your day
to come here on what
is a beautiful,
beautiful day here in DC.
I don't know how many of you are
fans of the TV show Jeopardy,
but a couple of days ago there
was a category called Memos.
And the question was,
the memo from Germany,
the blank check memo
from Germany
to this country helped
precipitate the outbreak
of the First World War.
And I'm sitting in my
living room and I'm like,
"My kids should know this.
My dog should know
this from living
with me for so many years."
Two of the contestants did
not even bother to ring in
and the third responded Russia
which is not only wrong,
it is galactically wrong.
So it was a reminder to me
that obviously we as a society,
we as a country need to
be talking and thinking
about this event, the First
World War, which I hope
by the end of today
you will come away --
even if you know
a lot about it --
thinking that you need to
know even more about it.
A friend of mine says a good
historian makes the familiar
unfamiliar and the
unfamiliar familiar.
So I'm hoping we do a
little of both here.
But obviously we need to be
doing much more discussion
and much more dialogue.
So I'm just delighted
to be on this panel.
I'm thrilled to be here in this
gorgeous building and I want
to thank everybody from
the Library of Congress
for the exhibit and the
invitation to be here,
and the chance to be with
my fellow panelists here.
Margaret told me to
stick to about 10 minutes
which most academics are
very uncomfortable with.
So I'm going to see if I can do
a very big topic very quickly.
I'm going to talk about
America's relationship
to the world in terms of foreign
policy and in terms not just
of the American elite who's
making foreign policy,
but in terms of what the
American people themselves are
debating about what they think
the United States ought to do.
And in the book that
Margaret mentioned,
I talk about America's
relationship
with the First World War of
being kind of an hourglass.
And the metaphor that I'm using
is that in 1914 it's very wide
with a lot of different
viewpoints among Americans,
many of which are beautifully
displayed in the exhibit here.
I argue in the book that by
the time you get to April 1917,
there's very little debate
among Americans about whether
or not entry into the
war is the right thing.
They may not like it, they
may be upset about it.
They may be opposed to the
policy that got us to the point
that we were in in 1917.
But there's actually
very little debate
that the country had tried
everything else; now we're in.
As early as late October 1918 --
that is even before the
armistice is signed --
you see the hourglass
begin to open up again
with a wide variety of
viewpoints among Americans
about what this war
ought to be about
and what America's relationship
to the peace process
ought to be.
And it's an oversimplification,
but I only have 10 minutes;
I would argue the great
American disillusion is not
with the war itself.
It is with this process
of peace.
It is with the reality that
Americans are beginning to see
and the people that are
in the Paris Peace Conference
are noting it as early as March
or April of 1919, that the
world is likely to be worse
on the other end of it than
it was at the beginning.
And William Bullitt
who would later go
on to be the first
American ambassador
to the Soviet Union left
the Paris Peace Conference
about midway through
and he wrote a letter
to his mother I think in which
he said, "I'm going to go lie
on the sand and watch
the world burn to hell."
And he's on a little bit of an
extreme, but there are a lot
of Americans who are
very uncomfortable.
Tasker Bliss who was the
American military representative
to President Wilson is writing
letters back to his wife
that are incredibly
pessimistic about the way
that this process is going.
So what I want to do is cover
a little bit of that debate.
I'm really not going
to talk very much
about Woodrow Wilson at all.
I want to talk about the
people who are advising him,
the people back in the United
States who are observing this.
And since I only
have 10 minutes,
I want to break the American
people really into two groups.
And what was surprising to
me without getting partisan
or political was that the 2016
debate about America's role
in the war sounded at least
to me very much like
the 1919 debate.
And I don't know whether the
candidates involved recognized
it, but it certainly
struck a chord with me.
So what I want to do here is
talk about those two groups.
One group is really
arguing for multilateralism,
which is really an argument for
connecting the United States
to the world either through
institutions or through trade
or through some other mechanism,
connecting all the nations
of the world together
with the underlying theory
that the more nation-states
were connected to one another,
the more incentive they
would have to cooperate.
And the less incentive they
would have for conflict.
And the argument ran --
it's a very complex argument
but I'm going to boil it down
to ridiculous simplicity.
One was that in order
for markets to work,
multilateralism had
to be in place.
In other words, if markets
are going to be global
as they were before World War I,
and everyone hoped they would be
after World War I,
multilateralism is the only way
to get those markets
to function.
Second, multilateralism was
the best way to get states
to have an incentive
to cooperate,
either through binding
arbitration
or through some sense
of collective security.
The idea here being that even
Germany, even pariah states
like Germany, could be
brought into this system,
could be incentivized
into the system.
And third, that multilateralism
could grow the international pie
so that the world didn't have
to become a zero sum game.
Competition for markets,
competition for natural
resources
which had fueled imperialism
wouldn't necessarily have
to be zero sum anymore.
And again, you don't have
to agree with any of this.
You don't have to like any of
this, but it's a dominant way
of understanding America at
the end of the First World War.
And I think you can clearly
hear echoes of it in the way
that some Americans
think about their role
in the United States today.
And if I have time at the end,
if Margaret doesn't
give me the hook,
I want to talk a
little bit about the way
that vision gets implemented at
the end of the Second World War.
Because we do it a
little bit differently,
although the fundamental
vision remains.
The second group, and I know
Charles is going to talk
about them in greater detail,
and he may disagree with some
of what I'm about to
say, but go by the name
of isolationist in 1919.
But I think we've somewhat
misunderstood what this group
stood for.
They are led by Henry
Cabot Lodge
who had an office
right in that building.
And they are led until his death
in 1919 by Theodore Roosevelt
as well, at least
intellectually.
And they made a lot
of arguments,
a lot of very sophisticated
arguments, but I'm going to boil
down just three of them.
One is that great power
simply shouldn't play the game
by the same rules
that small powers do.
And a line that Lodge threw out
that America is not Ecuador,
that great powers play the
game by different rules.
And I was just reading
on the metro down here,
the United States only submitted
to binding arbitration one time
in its history, just once.
Right, and I used to
joke with my students
that the Army War College
and sometimes still do,
if there's a treaty out there
that only one nation
hasn't signed, you can count
on it being a super power.
You can count on it being
a great power, right?
The idea being that
you don't need
to play by those same rules.
Are you disagreeing
already, Charles?
>> Charles Kupchan:
Yeah, you're way off.
>> Michael Neiberg: Am I?
Okay.
[ Laughter ]
And I'll turn it over
to you in a minute.
The second is a Constitutional
question.
That is, if you join a
multilateral organization,
as the League of Nations
at least in writing seemed
to suggest, if the League
of Nations committed the United
States to use military force
to resolve a situation,
it was taking a power
that was the responsibility
of those people
in that building right there.
That in effect it was by
definition unconstitutional,
that the power to send
American troops overseas,
the power to raise an
army, those were reserved
to the United States Congress
and the United States
Congress only.
And third, the argument
that I think Theodore
Roosevelt would have made more
articulately had he not
passed away in early 1919,
is that you cannot ask the
global system to function
in ways it's not
designed to function.
And for people like Theodore
Roosevelt, it was designed
for nation-states to operate
independently of one another.
It's not really set up for
nation-states to cooperate.
Now to be sure, these
arguments got quite personal,
especially between Woodrow
Wilson and Henry Cabot Lodge
who despised one another,
and between Wilson
and Theodore Roosevelt
who despised one another.
But I think we also have
to understand the ideological
differences in the way
that they were seeing the world.
And what I try to do at least
with my students is say
it's a mistake to think
of the war producing
an American identity.
And the reason I say
it's a mistake is
because I think it projects
into the past a unanimity
that simply didn't exist.
There was debate then
as there is debate now
about the way the United
States is supposed to do this.
Do I have two minutes left?
Or am I already out?
>> Margaret MacMillan:
Yeah, you're pretty close.
>> Michael Neiberg:
I'm pretty close.
Okay, so let me just very
quickly state that at the end
of the Second World War,
the Americans decided
to play this game a
little bit differently.
And Harry Truman when he
took the oath of office
after the death of Roosevelt
did it underneath a portrait
of Woodrow Wilson for a reason.
He wanted to keep Wilson's
vision of multilateralism
but the institutions
that he wanted to create
and many Americans wanted to
create -- the United Nations,
the World Bank --
would be institutions
that could not harm
the United States.
The UN especially with
the Security Council vote.
So the basic fundamental
idea remains,
but the way in which you're
going to engage it will change.
I think I'll stop there and
let Charles tell me everything
that I got wrong.
Thanks very much.
>> Margaret MacMillan:
Thank you.
Charles?
>> Charles Kupchan:
I think you're next.
>> Margaret MacMillan:
Oh sorry, I'm next.
Yeah, sorry.
So one of you is going to
have to tell me when I'm going
on too long, so I'll trust
one of you to do this.
I'm going to look
at just the way
in which the United
States had changed
and the way it was
participating in the world
and what the Paris Peace
Conference meant, the conference
at the end of the
First World War.
Even before the war, the United
States had begun that process
of transforming what
was tremendous economic
and demographic and
geographical power
into actual military power.
In 1900 the United States ranked
I think 14th among the world's
military powers.
It had a very small army.
It had a very small navy.
Even before 1914
it was beginning
to grow its military power.
Because it's one thing to
be economically powerful
and occupy a huge and important
landmass, and another thing is
to actually transform
that into military power.
It was also beginning
to expand territorially,
of course across the United
States itself but also
in the Pacific, into
the Caribbean.
Theodore Roosevelt as president
instituted a two-ocean navy,
and the United States was
becoming more involved
in international organizations,
international meetings.
It went to the Hague
Disarmament Conferences.
It got involved in brokering
the Treaty of Portsmouth
between the Russians
and the Japanese
after the Russo-Japanese War.
And so it was not unused
to international affairs
by the time the First
World War started.
And Woodrow Wilson who
was sitting at the bedside
of his first wife who
was dying did break away
as Europe plunged towards war
to offer his services and that
of the United States
as an arbitrator to try
and bring some sort of peace
before Europe plunged into war.
The Americans and Wilson
of course watched what
was happening in Europe
with a certain amount
of horror and dismay.
But increasingly, large
numbers of Americans,
and I think this is true of
Wilson himself, became convinced
that the United States
had a duty to try not just
to bring the war to an end,
but if necessary, to intervene.
And a number of things
contributed to that.
The sinking of the Lusitania
for example was a moment
American lives were lost
and it was a moment in which
American public opinion I think
began to shift from
neutrality to both sides
to really hostility to what
they saw not so much as Germany,
but what they saw as
Prussian militarism.
This became something of
an ideological crusade,
and then of course the folly
of the German high command
in reinstituting unrestricted
submarine warfare in 1917
and beginning to sink
American freighters
and destroy American lives.
And then offering in
the Zimmerman Telegram
to Mexico their support
if Mexico would attack
the United States and try
to seize back territory that
the US had taken from Mexico
in the middle of
the 19th century.
This really was a
decisive shift.
Woodrow Wilson went to Congress
and got a declaration
of war in April 1917.
But he was very clear from the
beginning, and I think a lot
of Americans supported this view
that the United States was
not a power like other powers.
And it's symbolic I think
that the United States
never became an ally.
It was always an
associate power.
And this was something the
Americans took very seriously.
They were there to try to
bring an end to the war.
They were not there,
they kept on saying,
to gain anything for themselves.
Of course they did.
The United States expanded
economically enormously.
It moved into British markets.
By the end of the war it was
a much greater power both
in military terms but
also in economic terms
than it had been
at the beginning.
Now the American war
aims as enunciated
by Woodrow Wilson were very much
tied up with this peace aims.
This was a war, a
crusade for peace.
A peace he said in
his many addresses,
a peace without victory.
He wanted a community of power
to replace balance of power.
The old European
idea that as long
as the powers were balanced,
you wouldn't get conflict seemed
to Wilson and others
to be folly.
That a balance of power
was inherently unstable
and likely to lead to war.
He also talked about how
this was a war for democracy,
for the right of those
who submit to authority
to have a voice in
their own governments.
And I'm quoting from an
address he gave in April 1917
with the declaration of war.
"For the rights and
liberties of small nations,
for universal dominion of rights
by concert of free people,
and shall bring peace
and safety of all nations
and make the world
itself at last free."
And he talked also
about mechanisms
by which this might be
done in his 14 points.
Later on his four principles,
he talked about free trade --
although the phrase was
never one he used much,
but he certainly talked
about self-determination.
Unfortunately, he never really
defined it very clearly.
And this is one of
the real problems
with self-determination.
So he went to Paris and the
American delegation went
to Paris very much in the
frame of mind that it was there
to set the Europeans free.
It was there to tell
them how they were going
to make a better world.
It was there to make sure that
the sacrifices as they were seen
of Americans, of the American
public, of American soldiers,
of American sailors,
would not be in vain.
Now there are many myths
about what happened.
And I think perhaps the
most prevailing one,
persistent one is that Wilson
came as a sort of Galahad --
and this was certainly the
image given by his supporters --
and was greeted on the shores of
Europe by these black-hearted,
bestial Europeans who
didn't want anything
of what he was talking about.
And this I think
is utterly false.
A lot of Europeans had already
been talking before the First
World War about the very things
that Wilson himself
was talking about.
In fact, many of the ideas
he drew on for a community
of nations, for collective
security, for free trade
as a way of knitting together
the peoples of the world,
came from things
Europeans had been talking
about since the 18th and 19th
centuries and sometimes earlier.
And a lot of Europeans welcomed
Wilson as someone who is going
to bring a better world.
And of course, they knew --
I mean, if you were in Paris,
you could see what
the war had done.
And you got to the battlefields
on the western front
for the day, and these
had not yet grown over.
You could see what
that battle had done.
And so I think Wilson
came actually with a lot
of support both from
the American people
and from the Europeans
themselves.
So what went wrong?
And I think a number
of things went wrong.
I think Wilson himself
wasn't politically astute.
He did not make making the
peace a bipartisan affair.
He brought what was really
exclusively a Democratic
delegation and he brought one
or two nominal Republicans
that they had been
Republicans so far back
that no Republicans
recognized them as such.
And he made the election
of November 1918 a
partisan election,
"A vote for the Democrats
is a vote for peace."
And he did not manage
his relations either
with the Republicans
or with Congress well.
And in the end, I think
the treaty and the covenant
of the League of Nations --
it was embedded and it failed
in Congress because Wilson
wasn't sufficiently politically
astute to get it through.
I think also what went wrong is
that the expectations
were too high.
At the end of such a great
struggle and such loss --
and we have to remember what
that meant, particularly
for Europe but for
the world in general:
nine million men maybe dead.
Nobody knows for sure
how many men died
and how many more were going
to be wounded and destroyed
by the war, never
really to recover.
It was not a time that
was easy for making peace.
The real contrast I
think is with the end
of the Napoleonic Wars
in 1814-15 when Europe
and European powers
were ready for peace.
And this wasn't the
case in 1918-1919.
In fact, a lot of fighting
was going to go on up
until the mid-1920's in
the center of Europe,
in the Caucuses,
in the Middle East.
You also had two waves of
emotion if you want to call it,
ideology, that were rising
rather than declining.
By 1815, the excitement set off
by the French revolution
was over.
In 1919, the Russian
Revolution was only beginning
to have an impact on
the rest of the world.
And all over Europe,
there were going
to be revolutionary outbreaks.
What was also happening
was ethnic nationalism
because the world had
destroyed old empires.
Austria-Hungary had gone,
Germany had fallen to pieces,
Russia had fallen to pieces.
The Ottoman Empire
was about to go.
And suddenly all these peoples
who had wanted some sort
of autonomy now saw a
chance for full independence
in their own territory.
And so making peace in those
conditions was not easy.
I'm not sure anyone
could have succeeded.
My own view is they
didn't do such a bad job.
William Bullitt I think
was a young, impatient man,
highly idealistic, if I may
say so, very self-centered
and was furious because they
wouldn't listen to his advice.
And I think his attacks
and the attacks
of others were not recognizing
the very real political
and economic and social
difficulties that lay in the way
of making peace,
which is not to say
that it was necessarily
a good peace.
But I think what they
did was try and deal
with a range of problems.
They tried to deal with
the problem of Germany.
Germany remained a power.
In fact, in some ways
Germany was better off,
although the Germans
certainly didn't feel it,
in 1918 than it had
been in 1914.
It no longer had a
common border with Russia
which had given the Germans
and the German high command
nightmares for decades.
Poland had emerged on the map
of Europe to separate the two.
Instead of an Austria-Hungary,
it had a series of small
and quarrelling new or in some
cases old states like Poland.
And its infrastructure was
largely untouched by war
because virtually all of the war
on the western front
had been fought
on either Belgian
or French soil.
And although some of the war
in the east had been fought
on German soil, Germany came
out of the war less damaged
by war than the victors.
The treaty with Germany,
the Treaty of Versailles
which included the
covenant of the League
of Nations has often
been condemned as harsh.
John Maynard Keynes wrote
a famous attack on it
in The Economic Consequences
of the Peace.
It is difficult to see how they
could have done anything other
than impose conditions
on Germany.
As Georges Clemenceau the
French Prime Minister said,
"How can I tell the French
public they have to pay
for the damage that Germany
did to French soil and did
to French villages and
did to French industry?"
And the British prime minister
David Lloyd George felt the
same thing.
It was a treaty that
was loathed in Germany,
but I suspect they wouldn't
have liked any treaty.
Because what began to
happen almost as soon
as the guns fell silent
in November 1918 was
that the high command and
its supporters began to put
on the story that Germany had
not lost on the battlefields;
it had been stabbed in the
back by traitors at home.
So if you don't think
you're lost,
it's like people
who go to court.
If they think they have
a case, they're not going
to say the judge was
really fair and I lost,
but it was a fair decision.
People don't think like this.
And the Germans felt it
was an unfair decision.
They felt they had been
promised something.
They thought they'd
been promised
by Woodrow Wilson
they'd be treated gently.
They thought they
might grow in territory
because they'd been allowed
to absorb the German-speaking
territories of Austria-Hungary.
And they found they
weren't allowed to do that.
So I think Germany would not
have accepted any peace I think
that was imposed on it, and
peace was imposed on it.
And gradually in the 1920's
and 1930's, what you began
to get was the development
of other myths,
that Germany hadn't
started the war;
that it somehow had
just happened,
and so everyone was guilty.
And that again undermined
the legitimacy of the treaty.
So I think the Americans
contributed to the making
of that treaty, but they
didn't I think contribute
to the troubles that followed.
The troubles that followed were
a result of the First World War.
And the 1920's and '30's might
have turned out differently
if it hadn't been for
political decisions,
bad political decisions,
if it hadn't been
for the Great Depression.
The one thing I think
that came out of this
that I think was good was
that Wilson did give a vision
and a very powerful vison
of how the world might
be run in a better way.
We still haven't got there, and
we still haven't really figured
out how to end wars
without causing trouble.
And I think that is something
we should remember before we
condemn what happened in Paris.
So I'm sorry if I
went on too long.
You should have told me.
>> Harold James: It was
absolutely fascinating.
And thank you so much
for the invitation.
I'm just very happy to be here.
I think you've heard some key
themes already really very,
very beautifully and
very eloquently laid out.
The war was a great success,
but the peace was
a terrible failure.
And the hopes of Wilson --
Wilson was deeply disillusioned
after 1919, and he ended
his presidency in despair
and great, great sadness.
But Margaret was saying
that Germany wasn't really
in such a bad position at the
end of the First World War.
You should say that
the United States was
in this amazing position at
the end of the First World War.
The First World War really
transformed the geopolitics
of the world.
And the United States is really
a global power in 1918 and 1919
in the sense that it really
wasn't even in the 1890's.
And the story that
you heard already,
that the US military
is terribly,
terribly weak before
1914 applies equally
to the United States
as a financial power.
In the beginning of 1907, a
rather obscure immigrant banker
in New York called Paul Warburg,
although I think people now
know him better as Paul Warburg,
wrote a long piece saying
that the United States financial
system was about as advanced
as that of the Middle East
at the time of Hammurabi,
or that of Italy at the
time of the Mendecci.
And nobody really took
very much notice of that
until October of 1907.
And then there was an
enormous stock market crash.
It was one of the
biggest financial panics
up to that point.
And Paul Warburg suddenly
looked like a prophet.
And so he becomes the person
who's really instrumental
in designing a new
banking system
and a new central bank
very much altered.
His vision becomes the
Federal Reserve system in 1914.
And the United States is
a great financial power
in 1918 and 1919.
What does that really mean?
It means that an awful lot
of people owe money to you.
And the United States is the
world's biggest creditor.
But it's not really easy being
a creditor, because what's going
to make all these
people repay that money?
And so there's a
fantastic problem
about whether all the money that
was lent by the United States
to its allies during
the war, to Britain,
to France, will be repaid.
There's a hope that it will,
but it's not at all clear.
And there are all kinds
of sophisticated
arguments about that.
One of the problems
is that France
and Great Britain have
themselves also been great
creditors during the
World War, but they,
unlike the United States,
lent a lot of money
to the czarist empire, to
Russia, to imperial Russia.
Well, after 1917, Russia wasn't
going to repay any of that.
And so the British and French
make a relatively reasonable
case that they can't really
fully bear the consequence
of having to repay
their own debt.
Margaret made that point very
clear: France is wrestling
with the problem
of fantastically
expensive reconstruction
because the war was fought
in the west through France
and Belgium, not in the UK,
not in the United States
really, not in Germany.
And so France has to pay this.
So France is going
to be really limited.
So France and Britain
look at Germany as a way
of getting money to pay this.
And they go on a kind of
historical tour and see
that in 1870, 1871 after
the Franco-Prussian War,
France paid a big
sum of reparations.
After the Napoleonic Wars,
there was a quite modest sum
of reparations that
were imposed on France
in the Vienna Settlement.
But in 1919 it's really amazing.
Everybody wants to collect
money from somebody else.
Even in the most
bizarre circumstances.
For instance, in the early
1900's an indemnity was imposed
on China as a consequence
of the damage
that the Europeans had
suffered in attacks
by the Boxer Rebellion on
the European settlements.
They have to pay an indemnity.
In the First World War, China
joins the allies and as a reward
for good behavior, the
indemnity is cancelled.
Well, not cancelled, because
in 1919 it comes back again.
And that's a source
of immense resentment.
So a lot of the resentments
that Margaret correctly talked
about in the 1920's are
resentments of people
who actually have to
pay and find it very,
very difficult to pay.
So that's a really
problematic thing.
It sounds nice being
the financial superpower
of the world and having lots
of people owing money to you.
But the problem is
how to collect it.
And if you base your
future expectations
of your debt management
and your tax levels
and what you can pay American
citizens on the expectation
that you will be repaid, you're
basing that on an illusion.
And it proves to be an illusion.
In that sense, the story
that you have about the end
of the First World War
and the Great Depression,
they're interrelated topics.
It's that collapse
of the debt empire
that is the direct consequence
of the First World War
and the debts that
are at the end of it,
and they can't properly
be resolved.
Let me make just two little
observations at the end of this.
One is following Margaret
really on the peace treaty.
Could anything better
have been done?
It's actually hard to think
of it, because these debts
and the expectation that
they will be repaid --
and they're part of
the political fabric.
And in fact, in fact,
the treaty of Versailles
and the Paris Peace Settlement
was stabilizing and people began
to accept it in Europe.
And the oddity of it is that
it was progressively revised
and then the reparation
provisions almost completely
eliminated, except for a tiny
symbolic amount, in 1932,
in the summer of 1932.
And that actually is the fatal
movement for the development
of democracy in Germany.
Because as long as you
had that obligation,
as long as you had these ties,
the Germans had to negotiate,
had to try to get a little
bit of an improvement.
If it was lifted entirely,
you could have a radically
nationalist government
in Germany without
any penalties,
without any sanctions at all.
And so it's the lifting of
reparations in the summer
of 1932 that sets the stage
for the dictatorship
of Adolf Hitler.
If Hitler had become chancellor
of Germany before the summer
of 1932, he would
have completely failed
because either he would
have paid reparations
and then looked ridiculous
in the eyes of his followers
who would have abandoned him,
or he would have
not paid reparations
and the treaty is very clear
the French and the Belgian army
and maybe the British army
would have invaded the Rhineland
and occupied the Ruhr again.
So it's the end of
reparations rather than the fact
of reparations that
makes Hitler possible.
The second theme that I would
like to take up is something
that Margaret alluded to,
but I would like to make it
maybe a little more polemical.
But some people criticized
the treaty very bitterly
at the time.
It didn't do enough for
European reconstruction;
that's absolutely true.
But the people who said that
were really quite divided.
They could have made
a better system.
They could have thought of
a way of providing the kind
of financial assistance that
flowed to Europe in the middle
of the 1920's much earlier.
In October and November of
1919, there was some meetings
in the house of a Dutch banker,
Gerard Wiserink in Amsterdam,
where a number of
Swedish, Dutch, American,
Swiss bankers took part,
but also the great British
economist John Maynard Keynes.
And John Maynard Keynes by
this stage had a big problem.
He could really see
what should be done
to make the world better, but
he had poisoned the atmosphere
to such an extent by his
famous and polemical book,
The Economic Consequences of the
Peace, that it was unrealistic
that anybody in authority
in London or Washington,
let alone in Paris,
would listen to him.
And so this brilliant
intellectual,
and The Economic Consequences
of the Peace is a beautiful,
wonderful, eloquent book,
made sure that that nothing
practically could be done.
And unfortunately, that it seems
to me is still something that is
out there in that
there are many --
not many, but a few significant
very important economists
who think of themselves
exactly in this role
of John Maynard Keynes of
being a public intellectual.
Very evidently in the
recent financial crisis,
in the aftermath of
the financial crisis
and the European debt crisis,
Joseph Siglet or Paul Kruppman,
they see themselves exactly
in the legacy of Keynes.
And they do an incredible
job in making fun
of the European politicians
who are supposed
to make sense of the mess.
But the constructive
proposals really as in the case
of John Maynard Keynes in
1919 are simply not there.
And so Keynes and some of the
other critics of the peace went
on a great journalistic voyage,
but it was a voyage
that was destructive.
Because it actually
encouraged the fantasy
that you could get rid of all
of these debts at the same time,
rather than thinking, "Let's
tackle them one by one.
Let's do a piecemeal bit
of tinkering on this,
and let's gradually get the
world to be a better place."
So the quest for the best
was in this sense an enemy
of a lasting peace treaty.
Thank you.
>> Margaret MacMillan:
Charles, you can wrap it up
by disagreeing with us all.
>> Charles Kupchan: Okay.
I am the outlier up here
because I'm a professor
of international relations,
not a distinguished historian.
And as a political scientist,
our duty is to make
big arguments
that have no basis
whatsoever in fact or history.
[ Laughter ]
So I'm going to try to do that
and then let my esteemed
colleagues shoot me down.
And I want to spend a
lot more time talking
about what came before
Wilson than my colleagues.
Because we usually understand
World War I and Wilsonianism
in terms of either what went on
from 1914-1919, or the failure
of the League of
Nations, or what happened
in the '20's and '30's.
And I think understanding this
period required going backwards
and starting to tell the
story really from 1789.
And in particular to understand
how committed Americans both
in terms of their
mindset and in terms
of our political system
were to being isolationist.
Isolationism was
part of our DNA.
We defined ourselves as a
country that would stand apart
from the rest of the
world with such conviction
that it rivals the
conviction today that we have
about being a global power,
about being Pax Americana.
It was in our DNA.
It was part and parcel of
American exceptionalism.
And I see the struggle that
Wilson went through as well
as the struggle that
McKinley and Roosevelt
and Lodge before him went
through as this struggle
to alter American identity, to
alter the American narrative,
to alter what American
exceptionalism was about.
To try to turn this ship
around, and to get us away
from being an isolationist power
to becoming an internationalist
power.
And I think that we
tried in 1898 and failed.
We tried in 1917,
'18, '19 and failed.
And then we succeeded
eventually under FDR.
And so I want to
talk a little bit
about why I think the first two
attempts failed and then end
with some thoughts on the Cold
War and where we are today.
As I said, it is difficult
to understate the degree
to which isolationism -- and
by that I mean an unwillingness
to extend strategic commitments
beyond the continental North
American zone.
I'm not talking about
as a commercial power.
westward expansion.
What I'm talking about
is extending our reach
with durable permanent,
strategic commitments
beyond the motherland.
And yes, we aggressively
expanded westward,
and there are a lot of dead
people as a consequence.
Most people don't know it,
but we tried multiple times
to invade and annex Margaret's
country and we lost, repeatedly.
And then the last attempt was
made at the end of the Civil War
when Seward and others
said to the British,
we want you to compensate
us for supplying ships
to the south by giving
us Canada.
And that didn't work, although
the British did eventually I
think pay $15 million,
if the number is correct,
for the losses that
were incurred
by the Union during
the Civil War.
We made other attempts
in the 19th century
to annex territories:
Haiti, Cuba, Santo Domingo,
the Virgin Islands, Hawaii.
We mucked around
in Central America.
We sent our forces to protect
our traders and our citizens,
but we never created a consensus
to actually extend our reach.
Mainly because Congress
kept saying no.
To the degree that we went
beyond the continental zone,
it happened only twice,
at least as I can tell.
Maybe I will be corrected here,
but I could find
only two territories
that we took before 1898.
One was Midway in
1867 which we took
under what was called
the Guano Act.
And that's because Midway
had a lot of bird poop on it.
And bird poop is
good for fertilizer
and also for gunpowder.
No one lived on it, but a
US Navy captain claimed it
for the United States and
it became a US territory.
And the other was Pago-Pago
which was a nice deep harbor
in Samoa which we
took in the 1870s.
President Cleveland then
tried to offload it.
It didn't succeed,
but other than that,
I could find no instance
in which we extended our reach
beyond North America other
than one island covered with
bird poop and one deep harbor
in Samoa way off in the Pacific.
What led to this conviction
that we should stay
at home and stand aloof?
I will quickly run
through what I take
to be the main six arguments
that dominated the
political dialogue
in what I would call
a bipartisan way.
In some ways created a veto
over American state craft.
Beginning with Washington
and Jefferson
but really continuing right
through until the 1890's.
One, bank on our
natural security.
Big oceans to the
left and right,
relatively weaker neighbors
and generally nicer neighbors
to the north and south.
Why mess with that?
Two, we are a redeemer nation.
We are the new Israel.
We are going to save the world,
but we can't save the
world unless we remain pure
and pristine.
And if we go out and
become like other nations,
we will compromise the
American experiment.
We need to save the
United States
if we are to save the world.
But we can only do it
after we perfect ourselves.
Three, if we become a
country with foreign ambition,
we will compromise domestic
liberty and prosperity,
principally domestic liberty.
It's hard to overstate the
degree to which early Americans,
the founders in particular,
were much more scared
of domestic tyranny than
they were of foreign enemies.
And they therefore didn't
want a standing army.
They didn't want to
raise a big navy.
They wanted the separate states
to have their own militias.
And they thought that if we
got into great power wars,
we would end up being a tyranny
just like every other country.
Fourth, preserving
freedom of action abroad.
The unilateralism, that
was referred to earlier.
Fifth, protecting
social homogeneity.
Perhaps the main reason that
we never ended up taking Cuba
or Haiti or Santo Domingo or
other islands in the Pacific is
because they were
populated by nonwhites.
And effectively that was
a veto over expansion
because the largely
white population
in the United States did
not want to either rule over
or incorporate into the body
politic nonwhite individuals.
And then finally there
was a pacifist stream
of isolationism going back
to the Revolutionary War.
You find it in 1812, you find
it in the Mexican-American War.
It actually plays a very
important role during World War
I, and there are examples
of it in the exhibit here.
But I take those to be the
main strains of isolationism.
So that gets us to the 1890's
when finally after many,
many decades, McKinley
pushed by Lodge
and Mahon the naval
strategist decides
that we are finally going to
enforce the Monroe Doctrine.
And keep in mind the Monroe
Doctrine dates to the 1820's,
but we never really
did anything about it.
But finally we decide to
kick the Spanish out of Cuba.
And we go on essentially to
take Puerto Rico and Guam
and the Philippines,
and while we're
at it we finally take Hawaii.
And all of this is
in the service
of essentially a
humanitarian cause.
Because Cubans are suffering
under the hand of the Spanish.
And this is in part about the
next phase of manifest destiny.
I think Americans did buy into
the narrative of the 1890's
that the American
frontier had closed,
and that if the American
experiment and American dynamism
and social vitality
was to continue,
we needed to expand overseas now
that we had completed
the mission at home.
The problem is that what
we ended up with in 1899
and 1900 was nothing that looked
like what people
had been promised.
We turned into a
ruthless imperial power.
We were as oppressive and nasty
and brutish in the Philippines
as the Spanish were in Cuba.
And as a result, Americans
basically backed away from this.
They said the founders warned
us that if we went abroad,
we would lose our
special character.
We would become like others.
And that's exactly
what happened.
And the anti-imperial
movement grew.
Taft was elected.
He sort of pulled away
from the extension
of foreign commitments except
in the western hemisphere.
And importantly, he began to
talk about the legalization
and institutionalization
of international affairs.
We generally think of Wilson
as the father of that,
but keep in mind that the League
to Enforce Peace was founded
in Philadelphia in 1915 and
its first president was William
Howard Taft.
And then Woodrow Wilson gave an
important speech to the league.
I think it was not that much
longer after it was founded,
but you begin to see the
American people move away
from the kind of realist
expansion imperialism
to more a Wilsonian version
that is much more in keeping
with American traditions.
And so I see Wilson and the
reaction against realism as sort
of growing out of
the events of 1898.
He was a logical
reaction to what happened.
The story I would tell
about what happened during
World War I is in some ways
that Wilson overcorrected.
He did the idealism
but he forgot
to tell the realist story.
And it's interesting that
I, in addition to Margaret,
actually wrote down major
chunks of the speech
that he gave April 2nd in 1917,
because it's a remarkable
speech.
I would encourage all of
you to go read it tonight.
There is not one
reference to real politic.
It's all about democracy
and justice
and freedom of all peoples.
And in fact, he disavows any
hint or whiff of realism.
He says, "We have no
selfish ends to serve.
We desire no conquest,
no dominion.
We seek no indemnities.
We seek no material
compensation."
That is pie in the sky, right?
That is in my mind --
and I think the mind of many
Americans -- overreaching.
And so I think part of
the reason that in the end
of the day Wilson fell short
is that he overcorrected
for the realism, for the
republican imperialism
that came before him.
And he tried to sell a piece
that he couldn't convince the
individuals that were talked
about earlier, the
Lodge's, the Roosevelts.
It was too idealist for them,
and it was too idealist
for the world.
The world was still
an ugly place
where lots of people were dying.
It didn't correspond
to the vision
that Wilson was laying out.
So yes, I agree with Margaret
that he failed in part
because he was stubborn and he
forgot about bipartisanship.
But I also think it was a vision
that was simply too idealistic.
It resonated with
American exceptionalism.
America's past.
It resonated with manifest
destiny, but he went too far.
Final comment I'll
make is that I think
in some ways what we saw
during the Cold War was the fix
to the problem.
Equal parts realism
and idealism.
FDR was in some ways a clone
made by taking McKinley, Mahan,
Lodge and Wilson and
smushing them together.
>> Margaret MacMillan:
That's a lovely image.
>> Charles Kupchan: Right?
Because he did support
a rules-based
international system.
The United Nations
came into being.
But he was also a realist.
He understood power politics.
And in the Cold War, we were out
there to kind of save the world.
We were out there to
Americanize the system.
But it was also within the
bounds of power realities.
And I think that's in
part why it resonated
with the American people and
enjoyed bipartisan support.
My final comment is
that I think this story
that I've been telling
is very important today.
Because I think the
American past is coming back.
Margaret mentioned an article
I published recently called
Trump's 19th Century
Grand Strategy.
And I think there is
an enormous resonance
between what Trump is doing
and the pre-Wilson,
pre-1898 America.
The unilateralism.
The isolationism.
The racial-based
anti-immigrant sentiment.
The protectionism.
We were not a free
trading nation.
I don't think Trump
actually understands it
because I don't think he reads
a lot of American history,
but I do think there
is remarkable resonance
between his narrative and the
narrative that existed prior
to our push outward
that began in 1898
and continued with Wilson.
And I do think that today we are
at a crossroads in some ways.
I think much of the world
that Wilson envisaged came
to life during World War
II and during the Cold War.
I worry that it is
today slipping away.
Slipping away because neither
the realist arguments nor the
idealist arguments
are being made.
Slipping away because the world
isn't going America's way.
It is becoming more
illiberal, not more liberal.
And that makes me worry that
the United States will go back
to the narrative that dominated
this country for so long,
and that is, "If we can't
change the world, then we need
to shield ourselves
from that world.
Because it's a dirty,
ugly, nasty place,
and we need to tend
our own garden."
>> Margaret MacMillan:
Thank you.
I think we've had a, I think,
very good demonstration
of why history matters and why
we need to think about the past.
Because it does help us to
think about the present.
It raises issues which
are important today.
And I think I'm going to ask
each of the panelists to comment
on what each other has said.
But I'd also just like to
raise some general questions.
And one is it seems we've
been talking about the nature
of power, what it actually is.
I mean, we tend to think
too often you can count it.
You can count numbers of tanks.
You can count numbers of heads.
You can count GDP per head,
and then you can somehow
say what power is.
And I think what they found in
Paris in 1919 and afterwards
and what powers are finding
today is that projecting power
and what power is,
is complicated.
And you can't always
get your own way,
no matter how powerful you are.
And I think in Europe in 1919,
here are the victors sitting
in Paris; they can't stop
the Czechs and the Poles
from fighting with each other
because they haven't got a way
of actually getting
their forces over there.
And we think of what's
happening in Afghanistan.
It's 17 years now NATO
forces have been trying
to impose some sort
of order there.
And these represent some of
the most powerful nations
in the world, and before
that it was the Soviet Union.
So I think that's one thing
we've been talking about.
We've also I think been
talking about how you end wars.
How do you actually deal with
those who have been defeated?
How do you deal with
those who have won?
How do you build
a lasting peace?
And this is not easy.
I mean, St. Augustine
said you should end a war
as if you wanted peace,
but it's not easy to do.
And I think these are still
issues we're grappling
with today.
And I think we've also seen
in the comments today the
importance of perception.
Perception may be wrong, but
it can be a very powerful force
in politics both domestically
and internationally.
And ideas matter as well.
What people think
happened matters.
What sort of world they
want to see matters.
I mean, one of the things
that Wilson was facing
in Paris was an alternative
vision of the future,
and that was the Bolshevik one.
And both those sets of ideas
were going to be very powerful
through the rest of the century
and I think still
have resonance today.
And it's a question I
guess I have for the panel.
The role of public opinion.
The Congress of Vienna,
they made peace
without really worrying about --
there was nothing
called the public.
And there was some
domestic opinion,
but it was usually very small
and confined to a few people.
And so they could sit down in
Vienna and do some horse trading
and they could come up
with a workable peace,
and they did actually.
In Paris, they had
huge public scrutiny,
huge public expectation and I
think Wilson himself said it
on the boat going over to Paris.
He said, "I foresee an
agony of disappointment,"
because there were so many
hopes, so many dreams.
And public opinion is
not always very coherent.
And what the publics in the
winning countries wanted
in 1919 was a better world, but
they also wanted someone to pay
for the mess of the old world.
And these weren't always
necessarily consistent.
And I guess the final question
I have for the panelists is --
you know, these settlements
at the end
of the World War still
have a very bad press.
I think unfairly so.
But as Harold James
said, the polemic written
by Keynes is still
enormously powerful.
It's still in print.
It's the envy of every academic.
He wrote it in six weeks.
It was an instant bestseller
and it's never been
out of print since.
And it is wonderful to read.
It is totally unfair and I
think what he was suggesting was
totally unrealistic.
I mean, at one point he
suggested not in the book
but to Lloyd George and others,
that all inter-allied
debts should be cancelled
and then there'd be no need
to collect reparations.
I mean, this was a
lovely and unique idea,
but politically impossible.
I guess the question is, why
do the peace settlements have
such a bad reputation?
Why are they seen
as so disastrous?
When in fact if you look at the
peace settlements at the end
of the Second World War, you
compare how Germany was treated
after 1919 and how it
was treated after 1945,
it was never occupied in 1919.
As Harold James has said, it
never ended up paying that much
in the way of reparations.
It did lose territory but a lot
of that was territory it
had seized from Poland
in the partitions of Poland at
the end of the 18th century.
In the Second World War,
Germany was devastated,
its cities were leveled.
The whole of Germany
was occupied.
It was ultimately divided.
Reparations were seized
whenever they could be seized
by the Russians who
took anything
from their sector they
could get their hands on.
And yet we never hear about
how the way Germany was treated
at the end of the Second
World War led to conflict,
that it was a disaster.
And it just seems to me
an interesting question.
Why is it that we have
this persistent idea
that what happened in
1919 was a disaster
that led directly to 1939?
And we don't have that view
of what happened in 1945.
Anyway, I don't know what
order you'd like to comment in.
Perhaps, since you started,
Michael, would you like to?
>> Michael Neiberg: Well,
three thoughts come to me.
I'll try to do them
very quickly.
I think one thing
that's happening in 1919,
and it's happening now that
is extremely difficult,
and Charles you can speak
to this because you've been
on the inside of this, is that
the world is changing in ways
that the people making
decisions can't fully grasp.
And what's happening
I think in 1919,
there are three massive
paradigm shifts
that I don't think the
leaders of 1919 fully grasped.
And I'm just going to comment
on them very quickly
and then move on.
One is that the four
main terrestrial empires,
the Ottoman, German,
Austria-Hungarian
and Russian, are just gone.
They're not reformed.
They're gone.
And they need to be replaced.
That space has to be filled.
Second, I mean, I used to teach
the peace process by starting
with the Amritsa Massacre
in northern India.
Also as a way of saying that the
Europeans really do believe they
can go back to a status
quo ante in their empires.
And they can't.
There's no way.
And the third paradigm
shift is the development
of these two ideologies
that will dominate the '20's
and especially the 30's,
Bolshevism and Fascism.
Margaret rightly pointed
out they're perfectly aware
of Bolshevism and they're trying
to figure out what it means.
The second observation that
I would very quickly make,
I think one of the reasons that
this system is so difficult
to do and making peace
is so difficult to do is
that the solutions in a peace
treaty are normally political
and economic.
But the problems are
also cultural and social.
So I was in Israel a couple
of years ago on the West Bank
on the Israeli side
talking to both sides.
And what kind of dawned on
me is that what we're trying
to do is fix the political and
economic and hope the social
and cultural just
comes along with it.
And my impression, picking
up on things I've heard
from other people in there,
that that pattern may
need to be reversed.
And that's a much
harder thing to do
because you can't control
culture and social the way
that you can political.
And the third thing that
I just wanted to point
out real quick is what we
historians call contingency
and context.
And I think one of the
reasons why people were okay
with what happened
to Germany at the end
of the Second World
War is the sense
that the war was different.
That once soldiers had been
through Dachau, once they'd been
through Berg and Belsen,
there's no question
that you can't treat it the
way that you treated it before.
And the very last thing I
would say, I was trained
as a social historian,
which meant that I was
really trained not to look
for individual points
where history changes,
but to look for these grand,
sweeping events in history.
And I'm coming as I get older
as an historian to think
that maybe I was misled,
and that these contingent
moments really do matter.
I mean, Woodrow Wilson
won the 1916 election
by the second narrowest
margin in the history
of American elections.
Now the war is actually not that
big a deal in the 1916 campaign
because he and the
Republican Charles Evans Hughes
largely agreed.
But if another person
is put into that office,
how much of it goes differently?
Even though again
it's not an issue
that they're talking
about in 1916.
And Harold's point
which is just brilliant,
if they keep the debt structure
at least in place in 1932,
is that enough to prevent
something like Nazi extremism
from taking over inside Germany?
So I'm getting to think as I get
a little older, I at least need
to balance the structure
and the contingency
in the way we think
about these things.
And in an event like
peacemaking,
there are so many
contingent moments
where a decision could
have been made differently
at a different point
by a different person,
that it's entirely feasible
to envision other
outcomes coming out.
>> Harold James: I
couldn't be more awake.
[ Laughter ]
This is absolutely,
really the central topic.
I'm really glad we've
got to this comparison
of the post-war settlements of
1918-1919 and 1945, because yes,
1945 is clearly a much
more substantial success.
And it really builds
a stable order.
Just a couple of points on that.
One thing is that there was
no peace conference in 1945.
So there's no peace treaty.
There's nothing that's
the equivalent
of the peace of Versailles.
And legally the document
that brought an end
to the Second World War
in Europe is the two-plus-four
treaty that was signed
in October 1990 when the
Germany's became united again.
So they just dealt with it in
a very, very different way.
And I think on the other hand
if you mention particular bits
of Allied planning, if
you talk about Yalter,
you would get a very strong
reaction in many parts
of eastern and central Europe.
There's an enormous feeling if
you just have the word Yalter.
It's portrayed in
the same way --
it's like talking to Hungarians
and mentioning the word Freanor.
It produces an explosion.
And so it's just
very, very difficult
to produce a peace treaty.
But what happened in 1944 and
1945 is that the world produced,
the Allies produced, a working
political and economic order.
And that was enormously
successful.
I think also, I love the way
that Charlie put it together
in saying that FDR and Truman
synthesized American history
and bring it to a
kind of culmination.
But in a sense, the
1944-45 settlement was also
very partisan.
It was designed to
lock in the New Deal
on an international level.
And Roosevelt and
Truman were really aware
of that and they pushed that.
The bit that I'm most
familiar with are the financial
and monetary arrangements
made at Bratton Woods.
And they are exactly
designed to allow the New Deal
to live internationally because
it's recognized I think rightly,
and it's one of the key
insights of that period,
is that you can't
have either prosperity
or peace in one country alone.
And so Henry Morgenthau put it
very brilliantly at the opening
of the Bratton Woods
conference, that prosperity
and peace are indivisible.
And you can't expect them --
that goes very much
to Charlie's point.
You can't expect the United
States to be prosperous
and peaceful if the rest
of the world is not.
But in order to do that, it
needs a specific architecture.
And the elements of the New
Deal -- I mean, for instance,
really going into detail, how
to make the modern economy work,
how to stop the disasters
of the Great Depression.
It's about monetary policy,
it's about financial policy,
but it's also about
competition policy.
And the people who designed
the competition policy
in the second part of the
New Deal were the people
who then went to Germany
and broke up all the cartels
that had been the key feature
of the German industrial
structure before.
And then in turn, the people who
made the new cartel settlement,
anti-trust settlements in
the German case in 1949
and later became on a
European level the key people
who pushed this through
in the European community
and the European Union.
So there is a real
learning from the past,
but a sense that there's a
kind of structure that needs
to be internationalized.
And that's why I
think another part
of the complicated question
is, do ideas matter?
Yes, they do matter enormously.
And this was really a global
vision of interconnectedness.
>> Charles Kupchan: On the
question of war settlements
and peacemaking, I'd offer
three quick observations.
The first picks up on
something that Michael said
about I think some
misconceptions
about how peace breaks
out, and the sense
that I think people tend to
focus a little bit too much
on functional explanations and
getting the economics right
and getting parties
that are hostile
to trade with each other.
I haven't so much looked
at peace settlements,
but I have done a lot of
work on when peace breaks
out among longstanding
adversaries.
And I've found no evidence to
support the claim that it's
about economics, that
it's about transactions.
It is basically about diplomacy
and reconciliation
over the core issues.
So if you take the US and
the UK and we keep in mind
that we were enemies for
most of the 19th century,
the key turning point was
a settlement that emerged
through arbitration over the
border between British Guyana
and Venezuela when the United
States stuck it's schnaus
in to this situation and
asked the British to go
to neutral arbitration
and eventually they did.
And then we started settling
all kinds of other things.
The border of Alaska, you
mentioned fishing rights.
And then the traders get in.
Then the transactions
start to matter.
But if you don't fix the
underlying core diplomatic
geopolitical problems,
I don't think it works.
Second observation I would make
is I think a lot depends on --
I think one of the mistakes of
the World War I settlement was
that Germany was
not a stakeholder.
Germany was acted upon.
That's not true at the
end of World War II.
Odenower was a major
figure in the post-war era.
Margaret mentioned
1815 and the Concert,
the powers that formed
the Concert.
Yes, they were the victors
in the Napoleonic Wars,
but in 1818 they
had the good sense
to invite France to participate.
They gave France a seat at
the table and that's one
of the reasons that
the Concert worked.
I think to some extent
we have made a mistake
in the post-Cold War settlement
by not really making Russia feel
like it had a seat at the table.
This is probably not the place
to talk about the enlargement
of NATO, but I think in
some ways it was a mistake
to use NATO to create a post-war
European security architecture,
because it's basically
left the Russians feeling
as if they're out in the cold.
Final comment I'll make, and
this is more of a question
and I guess it will push us in
a somewhat different direction.
But I was thinking about this
this morning, and it's relevant
to the speech that you
and I both mentioned
of April 2nd, 1917.
If you look at Wilson prior
to his decision to go to war
after Germany starts
sinking US merchant vessels,
he basically attributes moral
equivalence to the belligerents.
He says that the war in Europe
is really about a war emerging
from countries committed
to the balance of power.
This is just another garden
variety European case of avarice
and jealousy and intrigue.
And he doesn't really
attribute it to regime type.
If you look at the speech
that Margaret and I refer to,
when he's making the case
for war, he spends a lot
of time talking about Prussian
autocracy and about the need
to build a world that rests
only on democratic people,
countries with freewill.
And I'm wondering if
any of my colleagues
who have studied this much
more closely than I can speak
to Wilson's change of mind.
Did he actually think that
regime type mattered much more
in 1917 than he did in 1914?
Was this a tactical maneuver
because he knew it
would resonate
with American exceptionalism?
Anyone have any thoughts
on that?
>> Margaret MacMillan: Michael.
>> Michael Neiberg:
He tended to believe
that democratic states don't
go to war with each other,
democratic peoples don't go to
war unless they're attacked.
So I don't think
Wilson was so nave
as to believe you fix one
problem and you fix everything.
But by and large,
democratic states,
states where the rules have
to answer to their people,
are less likely to engage
in destructive wars.
At least that's what
he believed.
I talk about this a lot,
when I go to audiences
where there are large German
populations and they say, "Well,
my grandparents came
from the old country."
Americans understood Prussia
as being a different entity
from Germany, as did the French,
as did even many Germans.
So when you start
to look at this,
there are many German Americans
who are not from Prussia,
who are arguing very
different things
about what they think is
happening in the old world.
And they can live with a war
that isn't against Germany
but is against the
Prussian government,
which I think is part
of the reason why Wilson
is parsing his words
so carefully in April.
And it's the same thing that
President George W. Bush did
when he said, "We're not going
to war against the Iraqi people.
We're going to war
against their government."
But that's pure Wilsonianism.
>> Harold James: If I could,
there's a particularly sort
of difficult story
about this transition.
Because in 1914 it was a
bit problem for both Britain
and France if they were going
to try to present the war
as a war for liberalism.
Their ally was clearly the
most autocratic power in Europe
and the most despotic
power in Europe.
And so by April 1917, the
Czar has been overthrown
and that problem was removed.
But there's also a sort
of conceptual issue
that I think is very
interesting at the root of this.
That in a way, the 1918-1919
vision is the 1815 vision
flipped around.
Because the people
who made peace
in Vienna also had a vision of
how in order to prevent conflict
in the future you needed
to avoid the possibility
of ideological clashes.
And so it wasn't about
having popular governments,
but it was about having
monarchical governments.
As long as every
government was monarchical,
you would never get this crazy
kind of liberation experiment
that started in France in 1789.
And so it's exactly
the idea that as long
as you have a uniformity,
then you won't try
to impose your will on other
monarchs or other republics.
>> Michael Neiberg: We do forget
how unbelievably important the
abdication of the czar was to
American entry into the war.
>> Margaret MacMillan: Yeah.
>> Michael Neiberg: Because
it's only then that you can talk
about this is a war to make
the world safe for democracy.
>> Margaret MacMillan:
I do think there's a
moral element there.
I mean, Wilson blamed the
balance of power as many did
for the breaking out
of the First World War,
because they saw it
as inherently unstable
and big power politics.
But I do think there
was antipathy
to something called Prussianism.
It wasn't just the
regime in Prussia.
dominance of the Kaiser.
It was things like the burning
of the library at Luwan,
the execution of
Mercitias Kuvel,
the sinking of the Lusitania,
the sinking of other ships,
the Sussex for example.
I think this was seen as the
mark of an out-of-control set
of ideas and something
had gone badly wrong.
Because Wilson does say in Paris
that once the Germans are freed
from Prussianism, once they
become more democratic,
they can join the
League of Nations,
that they can redeem themselves.
So I think he enters seeing
that the Allied side has
got the moral upper hand.
And you're absolutely right,
once Russia has had
its revolution
and has a democratic government,
then it's very different.
Now one last word and then I
think we might throw it open
to these very patient people
who have been sitting here.
Any last words any
of you would like?
No? Okay.
>> Harold James: Sorry.
>> Margaret MacMillan: Yes.
>> Harold James: Just one
very, very obvious thing.
I think all my classes have
endless discussions about what
and who caused the
First World War.
But it's very, very difficult
to have that discussion
about who caused the
Second World War.
>> Margaret MacMillan: Yes.
>> Harold James: It's
a kind of no-brainer.
So in that sense, very, very
different situations, yes.
>> Margaret MacMillan: They are.
You can go to any
bookshop or library --
if you look at the books on the
causes of the First World War,
they go on indefinitely.
The causes of the Second World
War is usually one shelf.
We don't debate about it.
We're pretty clear
how it started.
Okay, we have two people
rushing around with microphones.
And can I ask you not to
make very long speeches
but to ask questions?
Thank you.
Over there, please.
>> At the very end in
Versailles when they're ready
to announce the treaty, at that
point didn't Wilson show himself
to be a realist?
Didn't he insist on, as
harsh as everyone had agreed
against Germany, when other
people were beginning to doubt
and maybe be willing to go
back and change something?
And my other question was
if it had been Charles
Evans Hughes instead
of Woodrow Wilson, might he
have had a different approach
to the peace treaty?
>> Margaret MacMillan:
That's very interesting.
I think Wilson felt, if I
can just go on the first part
of your question,
I think Wilson felt
that he had done the best
job he could have done.
And they'd put it together and
he always thought the League
of Nations would be the
body that would change it.
He said, "Whatever
we've done now,
it will be changed
by the League.
The League will help change
the treaty and it will adapt."
I don't think he
had any feelings
that the treaty was a mistake.
I think he felt they'd done
the best job they could.
>> Charles Kupchan:
I would just add,
I do think that by overselling
and then having to compromise
when he negotiated with
the Europeans on Germany
on other issues, he
disappointed the left.
And it's worth keeping in mind
that his initial secretary
of state was William Jennings
Bryan who resigned in 1915
over the preparedness
movement and the response
to Lusitania basically.
And that there was a strong
left-wing peace movement
around Bryan and Jane Adams and
others who weren't supportive
of Wilson because
they thought he caved.
So he mainly lost the fight
for the League of Nations
because of the irreconcilables
and people like Lodge
on the unilateralism versus
multilateralism issue.
But he also faced
trouble on the left
because they thought
he caved in.
>> Margaret MacMillan:
Anyone want to try
Charles Evans Hughes?
>> Michael Neiberg: Well,
there's no obvious
way to answer it.
But this gets to that question
I was talking about before.
The way I was trained
would say it's really
about the environment
and the context.
That the problem is the same
and the solutions are roughly
the same because the structures
of the globe are the same.
All those major changes
that I talked about.
But as I said, as I'm getting
older and studying this more,
I think a Charles Evans Hughes
administration might well have
listened to Taft and the ideas
of the League to Enforce Peace
which were slightly different
than what Wilson
was trying to do.
My sense is it probably
would have been different
at the margins, but the
fundamental problems would still
have been there and the problems
that faced Woodrow Wilson also
would face Charles Evans Hughes.
So not really sure.
It's what we historians
call a counter-factual,
and my line is always
that I would rather discuss
a counter-factual at a bar
than an academic setting.
Because there's really
no way to prove it.
>> Margaret MacMillan: But
it makes a good discussion.
Yes?
>> My question has to do
with why have we not
really discussed --
you briefly touched
on it at the very end
of your discussion --
the role of Russia?
And it seems to me this 100-year
misunderstanding of Russia
or not having an understanding
hardly of all of Russia --
in political discourse as
far as history is concerned,
if you look at all the
First World War exhibitions,
they're all about Great
Britain, France and the US.
Very little about Russia's role.
Hardly any at all,
or Turkey or Italy.
But especially Russia.
And I think just
tossing it under the rug
and never addressing the
history of what Russia did
in the First World War
and its accomplishments,
how much it helped
the Allied effort.
It comes up at the
peace conference.
There could have been some
representatives from Russia
at the peace conference.
>> Michael Neiberg: The
question is how do you do that?
>> Margaret MacMillan:
How do you do it?
>> Michael Neiberg:
So you're not going
to invite the Bolsheviks.
>> Margaret MacMillan: And
they wouldn't have come.
>> Michael Neiberg: And
And you really don't want to
invite the whites, the czarists,
because you really don't want
Russia to become czarist again.
And I would just state,
I think you're right
about the general perceptions.
But there are specialists
working in these areas
who are working in
these archives --
and I've never worked in
Russian archives, but my friends
who have, it is maddeningly
difficult.
It makes working in the
French archives that I work
in look incredibly easy, and
that is saying something.
>> Margaret MacMillan: Yes, yes.
>> Michael Neiberg: So there are
specialists working in Russia
and the Ottoman Empire and
Italy and doing remarkable work.
But it's not easy work to do.
>> Harold James: I think it's
a very important question.
And there are really bits of it
that are not sufficiently known
and not sufficiently understood.
But you know, maybe because
I'm a financial historian
so I come back to
these financial things.
Russia found it, of
all the great powers,
the hardest to fight a world
war, a novel world war.
They could fight a short war,
but they were out of resources.
And at the beginning of
1915, as a result of that,
there was really a
quite serious proposal
that there should be a
political union between Britain,
France and imperial Russia.
It's something that is
absolutely mind-boggling,
you know, what it
would have looked like,
what it would have meant
for Russian reform.
It invites one of those
counter-factual speculations.
>> Margaret MacMillan:
Yes, it does.
>> Harold James: But it might
well have been the better world,
but that wasn't realized.
And just the administrative
and the financial strain
was in the end too much.
What really destroyed Russia
in 1916 was the inability
to pay for the war.
The consequence was
hyper-inflation of the kind
that Germany had in the
middle of the 1920's, in 1923.
And in this hyper-inflation,
people lost any sense of wanting
to do anything and so the
economy just completely
broke down.
They couldn't feed
the troops anymore.
And the soldiers
started to melt away.
So it's an administrative,
bureaucratic collapse
that has an inability
to fund the basis of it.
>> Margaret MacMillan:
You're going
to have to put your hands up.
I've got the lights in my eyes.
Have we got another question?
Oh, over there, thank you.
>> Yeah, I'd like to
go to a different part
of the world for a second.
The war had impacts all over
the world, including in Asia.
Could you comment on how the
results of World War I led
to changes in Asia
and specifically the US
increasing involvement in Asia
in the lead-up to World War II?
>> Margaret MacMillan:
Should I start?
>> Michael Neiberg: Please.
>> Margaret MacMillan: I mean,
I think the United States
was already involved
in Asia before the
First World War.
And that involvement was
going to grow deeper.
I mean, the United States
had a huge naval presence,
and its acquisition of the
Philippines of course took it
that much closer to
the mainland of Asia.
And it had huge trading
interests as well.
What the First World
War did I think
in Asia was it helped weaken
the great European empires
and that was going to bring
about long-term change,
although they didn't
appear immediately
after the war to be weakened.
But they had been, and certainly
in India you had the development
of a broadly-based
nationalist movement.
What it did for two great
Asian powers is it left them
with significant resentments.
The Chinese were an ally
in the First World War
and they contributed
not soldiers but labor.
Something like 100,000 Chinese
laborers came and worked
in the north of France, and
you can still see the graves
of those who died there.
And the Chinese felt that they
would gain what Germany had
taken in China.
European powers were dividing up
China before the First World War
in what were called concessions.
They'd get the exclusive
rights to develop mines
or build railways or ports
in a particular area,
of ten on 99-year leases.
And Germany had concessions
in the Shandong peninsula.
And the Chinese thought,
"Rightly we've contributed
to the war.
We'll get those back."
Instead, the Allies
awarded them to Japan
because Japan was also an ally
and Japan had contributed.
There were Japanese naval ships
in the Mediterranean
helping to patrol.
And the Japanese
had at the beginning
of the war seized the
German concessions
in China plus various German
islands in the Pacific
and those were awarded to Japan.
Because the calculation made in
Paris was that China was weak
and divided and helpless and
Japan was coming to power,
and better to keep on
good terms with Japan.
And so the Chinese
resented this.
It became part of what was
called the May 4th movement
which was a nationalistic
cultural movement of resentment
and resistance to the west.
And it I think led fairly
directly to the establishment
of the Chinese communist party.
Because up to this point,
Chinese nationalists had looked
to the west; they
believed in liberal ideas,
they believed in democracy.
And this really helped
to change it.
The Japanese got what they
wanted but not everything.
And what they wanted in
the mandate of the League
of Nations was a racial equality
clause as it was called,
a clause which said something
about no discrimination
on the basis of religion.
But what the Japanese wanted was
no discrimination on the basis
of ethnicity and it
wasn't put in that way.
It was race in those
days, they called it.
And they didn't get it because
Woodrow Wilson was worried
about opposition at home.
The Australians were
vehemently opposed to it;
so were the South
Africans on racial grounds.
And so the Japanese didn't
get everything they wanted.
And that led to an undercurrent
and eventually it came
up into the surface in
Japan that, "We contributed
to the First World War but the
western powers still will never
treat us as equals."
And it fed into the
enhanced Japanese militarism
and nationalism of the 1930's
with really profound
consequences.
So the First World
War had in a number
of ways a really
real impact on Asia,
which in some ways we're
still seeing the results of.
>> Michael Neiberg: The
only thing I would add
to that brilliant
erudite description
of a complex problem
very quickly is
that it is exactly the
Shandong peninsula question
that drives people like
Tasker Bliss to disillusion
with the Paris Peace process.
It gives away every principle
that Bliss believed the United
States had entered the war
to fight.
And Bliss who's a dedicated
career soldier actually thought
about resigning his commission.
And he and several members
of the US delegation talked
about a joint resignation
until they realized it
just wouldn't matter.
And Bliss rights this
very beautiful letter back
to his wife in which he says,
"The only good thing that came
out of Shandong is my
conscience is clear."
>> Charles Kupchan: I would
just add this conversation
underscores the degree to which
Wilson is a complicated figure.
Because we tend to think
about him as this idealist,
forward-leaning visionary.
But he was also a racist,
particularly here in
the United States.
And he was an imperialist.
He was one of the most
interventionist presidents
in American history when it
comes to the western hemisphere.
In fact, he tried to pass
what was essentially the Platt
Amendment for Nicaragua.
The Platt Amendment came out
of the Spanish-American War
and it basically said the
United States can intervene
in your country whenever
we feel like it.
>> Margaret MacMillan: Yeah.
>> Charles Kupchan: And the
Senate actually rejected it.
I don't remember what it
was called, the equivalent
to the Platt Amendment.
So just to underscore that
this is a complicated guy.
>> Margaret MacMillan:
If I can just add a quote
from a British diplomat
before the First World War.
He said, "I am going to teach
the South American republics
to elect good men."
>> Michael Neiberg: Right.
[ Laughter ]
>> Margaret MacMillan: Yeah.
Is someone over there?
Yeah, just back there.
Thank you.
>> Yeah, I think one term you
sort of touched on with Japan
and what I think is really
important is respect.
I think Germany in part
went to World War I
because they were a new
great emerging power
and they didn't think they
got the respect they deserved.
And then I think the Treaty
of Versailles was extremely
disrespectful in their mind.
But also with Italy, they
didn't think they got respect.
Japan didn't think they got
the respect they deserved.
These are the countries that
go Fascist after the war.
And I think that's an
important aspect of this.
>> Margaret MacMillan: I'll ask
the panel if they agree or not.
>> Harold James: It may be worth
telling the story of the article
in the Treaty of Versailles
that created the most problems
and the most resentment in
Germany and why it was inserted.
So it's article 231.
It's at the beginning of
the reparation section
of the peace conference.
And it's the war guilt clause.
And the story of the debate
over who is responsible
for the First World War was
one that went on and on right
through the 1920's and beyond.
I mean, indeed up to this day.
And the foreign offices
of all the big powers produced
these editions of documents
that showed that it
wasn't them that did it.
It's quite a plausible case.
So why put this into the treaty?
Well, it was a relatively young
Princeton graduate lawyer called
John Foster Dulles who
insisted that this be included
because the argument
was a very legal one,
that you can't impose
an indemnity
without specifying the tort.
So there has to be something
that has been done long.
And in order to justify
the restoration claim
which was done simply
for the financial reasons
that we started out with, you
had to insert this tort clause.
And it's the tort clause
that is endlessly the subject
of pushback in the German
case, in the democracy.
>> Michael Neiberg: To
me it's less respect
than it is justifying
to your people the cost.
So again the case I know best,
the French, there's nothing
in the Treaty of Versailles,
and I mean nothing in the Treaty
of Versailles, that explains
to the average French man
or woman why 1.2 million
Frenchmen are dead.
The recovery of Alsace-Lorraine
just doesn't do it.
They don't care.
The extension of
concession rights
in Syria just doesn't do it.
So the question that the
French are asking at the end
of the war isn't so much,
did we get our respect?
It's, tell us again
why we did this.
Tell us again what went wrong.
That's to me the fundamental.
And again, to me that's
a sociocultural problem
that a political document
isn't going to fix.
>> Charles Kupchan:
I would just add
that I do think respect
is extremely important.
If I think today about the
grievances that a country
like Russia or China brings to
the table, a lot of it has to do
with humiliation and respect.
You know, the Chinese feel that
they were the Middle Kingdom
for centuries and then
they started to skid
in the 19th century and they
have been given the back
of the hand ever since.
The Russians, they
propagate that same narrative.
So in some ways, respect
and humiliation are
in the eyes of the beholder.
But there's no question that it
is an extremely powerful tool
in the hands of leaders.
>> Margaret MacMillan: We've got
a question over here somewhere?
We've got at least two.
Oh, sorry.
Is there -- I'm not
seeing very well.
Anything over here?
What about the people in the
middle who have been very quiet?
Okay, here we go.
Thank you.
>> Thank you.
I think there's been some
mention of the Middle East,
but in your book, there's a lot
of discussion about the Treaty
of Versailles and the effect on
countries of the Middle East.
>> Margaret MacMillan: Yeah.
Well, what came out of the Paris
Peace Conference was a series
of arrangements, and they
were sort of consolidated
at conferences after the peace
conference formally ended
about how to divide up
the Arab territories
of the Ottoman Empire.
And the British and
French and Russians
and Italians actually during the
war had arranged how they would
divide them up.
The Ottoman Empire had been the
sixth man of Europe for so long.
They felt it was probably
doomed to disappear
and indeed it did disappear.
And there was a feeling,
and I don't think
Woodrow Wilson disagreed,
that these people weren't
yet ready to rule themselves.
I mean, Wilson was all
for self-determination
for what he saw as advanced
peoples or advanced races.
I mean, this is the way
they talked in those days.
At one point there was a
question of having a mandate
over some part of Europe.
Wilson said, "You
can't have mandates
over civilized peoples."
But the peoples in the
Middle East and the peoples
in Africa were seen
as not yet being ready
to govern themselves,
if they ever would be.
It was seen that the Arabs
were probably further along.
And so part of what came out
of the Paris Peace Conference
and these subsequent
arrangements was an arrangement
that -- by this point Russia of
course was no longer involved
because it was in revolution.
And Italy had really
dropped out in a way.
It had fallen out with
its former allies.
So really it was the
British and the French
who divided up the Middle East.
The Americans were withdrawing.
Woodrow Wilson had
gone back to the US.
He had lost the treaty
fight in the Senate.
He was of course very
sick and was really not
in a position to do very much.
And I think the US was
turning its back on Europe
and beginning to regret.
[ Inaudible ]
The question is, is
today's turbulence
in the Middle East
an inheritance?
A lot of people would say so,
because the Arabs were
not consulted really
on how these countries are
going to be divided up.
Having said that, a number of
the countries, Iraq for example,
were created using boundaries
from the old Ottoman Empire.
Syria was carved up
a bit more and part
of what traditionally had
been seen as Syria was given
to a greater Lebanon, and that's
still resented by Syria today.
What also happened of
course is at the same time
as the Arabs were being
secretly divided up,
they didn't know
this was happening,
they were also being
encouraged to revolt
against the Ottoman
Empire with the promise
of some sort of Arab
independence.
And the third thing that
was happening was the Baltha
Declaration which part
of the former Ottoman Empire was
promised for a Jewish homeland.
And so these three came together
really to be resented enormously
by many peoples living
in the Middle East.
However, if I just could finish
here, I think there's a danger
in saying that things
that happened 100 years
ago are responsible
for all the problems of today.
And I do think there's a
tendency particularly among
intellectuals and leaders
and others in the Middle East
to blame all their
problems on outsiders.
And it seems to me
they've certainly got a lot
that they can blame
on outsiders,
but they've also got
responsibility for themselves.
And I do think it's being
psychologically crippling
for people in the Middle East
to be able to keep on saying,
"None of it's our fault."
And I'm not suggesting there's
any easy solution to this,
but it seems to me
that 100 years later,
can you really blame
arrangements that were made
in 1919 for everything
that's gone wrong
in the Middle East since?
I mean, there have been
dictatorial regimes
that have been unrepresentative
regimes.
There have been tyrants.
It's difficult.
I mean, I'm not saying I know
the answer, but I don't know
if the rest of the panel --
>> Michael Neiberg: I
was going to say one
of the things I'm happiest
about at the Army War College is
that my seminar group decided
that the wars America's fighting
in the Middle East should
together be called the War
of the Ottoman Succession.
[ Laughter ]
In other words, that we're
still trying to figure
out what political structure
will govern that part
of the world 100 years later.
And I take Margaret's point 100%
that I don't even
believe the Treaty
of Versailles can be
cited as a proximate cause
of the Second World War because
of everything that happens
in the 20 years in between.
Nevertheless, as Margaret
pointed out actually
in her book, the treaty
actually has two histories:
what it actually did
and what people kind
of remember that it did.
And both of those things
are very important.
>> Margaret MacMillan: Yeah.
>> Charles Kupchan: I would
just add to bring this
up to the present day, if you
go into the '20's and the '30's,
I think one of the reasons
that we became isolationist is
Americans were questioning both
the realist and the idealist
rationale for World War I.
And they were coming
up empty-handed,
and that's what began the
narrative particularly strong
in the 1930's that this was
a war pushed upon us by banks
and by finance and
by corporations.
The Nigh Committee.
>> Margaret MacMillan:
And arms manufacturers.
>> Charles Kupchan:
Because they couldn't come
up with another explanation.
And I think we're now
starting that narrative
about the Middle East.
Because if you look at
Iraq, Afghanistan, Syria,
Libya and you say, "What
do we have to show for it?
And is the Middle
East going our way?"
The answer is no.
And that is why I think we're
right now in this weird kind
of warp where the president
of the United States says,
"We're getting out
of Syria tonight."
And then the secretary resigns
and then Putin says,
"Oh no, we're not."
And it's a mess because we
are seeing this debate play
out before our eyes.
>> Margaret MacMillan: Sorry,
we can continue this
discussion later,
but I've got one
person back there who'd
like to ask a question.
So if you don't mind,
I think it was someone
in the middle back
here had their hand up.
Yes, that gentleman.
Thanks.
>> You implied that if
Wilson had brought some real
Republicans to Paris, that the
handling of the treaty back
in the United States
might have been different.
Would he really have
been capable
of having some Republicans with
clout with him at the treaty?
>> Margaret MacMillan:
Well, Roosevelt did.
FDR made it bipartisan.
>> Michael Neiberg:
Very self-consciously.
>> Margaret MacMillan: Yeah.
I think he learned
a lesson, don't you?
>> Michael Neiberg: Yeah.
He was picking his secretary
of war and secretary of navy
who were Republicans
consciously which is something
that didn't happen during at
least the war years for Wilson.
>> Margaret MacMillan: Yeah.
>> Michael Neiberg:
It's possible.
Again, we don't know.
I mean, it's possible that those
Republicans could have come
to Paris and been as
appalled as Bullitt and Bliss
and others were, and those
were people who admired Wilson.
And they might have
come back and said,
"You can't believe the
mess that we just saw."
I mean, that's distinct
possibility as well.
>> Margaret MacMillan: Yeah.
I think we've had
a long session.
I think people probably
want a reception.
Is it short?
>> It's short.
>> Margaret MacMillan: Okay.
Hang on. Let's get
you a microphone.
>> The question relates to
Wilson's personal psychology.
Was he coming apart
in many ways?
And had he been more vigorous
in the Paris Peace Conference,
might there have been, do you
think based on your research,
a vastly different outcome?
>> Harold James: Well, if I
may, it's very, very interesting
and important question.
Because it's a question
about the health
of the president of
the United States.
[ Laughter ]
And the story is indeed
that Woodrow Wilson suffered
from an enormously
high blood pressure,
untreated blood pressure.
There's a wonderful older work
by a Philadelphia physician
called Park which tries
to explain the nature of
international failures
of the 1920's and '30's in
terms of the blood pressure
and the strokes and the
case of Woodrow Wilson.
In the Great Depression,
Ramsey McDonald was suffering
from Alzheimer's disease.
Paul von Hindenburg the
German president who handed
over essentially to Hitler was
in advanced Alzheimer's disease.
So it does raise exactly
that kind of question.
And I think he had
a stroke in Paris
and it clearly incapacitated
him.
>> Charles Kupchan: Yeah.
I would add that I think
we should be careful not
to overstate how much depends
upon the particular individual.
Because I do think that coming
back to some of the comments
that Michael made, that the
nation was not in a situation
in which a bipartisan
center was available.
Really beginning in the
1890's, the Democrats
and the Republicans
split on foreign policy.
And Bryan who ran several
times for the presidency ran
on a very anti-imperialist
platform.
And you really saw the two
parties go their separate ways,
and so it would have
been hard for Wilson
to find the raw material.
One of the things that FDR
and those after him found was
that the country had changed,
largely because of
industrialization.
And a lot of southerners
moved to the northeast.
A lot of people enjoyed
rising incomes during
and after World War II.
And that created a sweet spot
or bipartisanship when it came
to foreign policy that
Wilson did not have.
And that we lost here
beginning in 1994.
And right now if you look at
how much bipartisanship is there
on anything, the
answer is very little.
And it's new that the
bipartisanship is gone
on foreign policy.
Because it used to be
restricted to domestic policy;
now it's infected everything.
>> Margaret MacMillan:
On that cheerful note --
[ Laughter ]
If I could on your
behalf ask you to thank --
I meant to mention
this at the beginning,
but there's also a great
team at the Kluge Center
who have done all this work
and have prepared
a reception for us.
So Dan Torello and all the
people he's worked with,
I think we should also thank.
But can I ask on your behalf,
may I thank the panel for this?
Thank you.
[ Applause ]